what's up everyone First Reactions just
watch The Flash here in Singapore out of
the theater in the car
wow this movie is a culmination of a lot
of what we've been wanting to see in the
DC Universe I mean this is really a
spectacle of sorts um I'm not going to
give you anyway any spoilers here
because people are trying to link them
online don't do that actually just watch
the movie and keep it to yourself at
least till after the first weekend
because there's so many little nuggets
of spoilers and and fun tidbits and and
there's some really cool things the
audiences were cheering they were
laughing they were tearing up it's an
emotional movie it's a heartwarming
movie but at the same time there's a lot
of action
um now in terms of the Multiverse how
it's explained it's explained very very
well here that's one thing I appreciated
because sometimes the Multiverse can be
convoluted uh from other movies out
there they explain it very very well
here Michael Keaton is awesome
I went to the theater the very first day
of the 89 Batman movie I remember that
day like it was yesterday and it felt
that same way watching this again he's
freaking amazing he brings the same
energy the same Gusto the same you want
to get nuts let's get nuts it's in there
I love it
um Ezra Miller I'm not going to talk
about all of the things he's been doing
on outside of his acting but I will tell
you that he does bring it to this film
he's fantastic I can't say he they uh
sorry I'm not really good with the
pronouns they are very fantastic uh they
really bring it and yeah Ezra Miller is
freaking amazing as the flash
um what else
I can't tell you too much else I really
can't because there's a lot of spoilers
to it uh Sasha Kaye as Supergirl it fits
in this movie I'm not going to tell you
exactly how it works into it but they
work it into the storyline really really
well and uh she's great she is fantastic
and I mean she looks kind of like Henry
Cavill so I guess they're trying to keep
that Vibe a little bit going
yeah interesting interesting stuff here
but uh
how does it end I'm not going to spoil
that for you because I believe that the
ending that we saw is the final film
because they've been talking about that
that they did not show the ending
previously in other screenings but this
one they did
um but there were cheers let's put it
that way there were some laughs and
there were some cheers and there were
some gasps so guys you want to check
this out I think this is one of the best
DCU movies we've seen thus far I know
James Gunn's taking over this they're
going to be doing a new slate of films
but
I'm glad well we got Aquaman coming up
this one is really cool and it's
definitely watchable and you guys are
gonna really enjoy it anyway guys if you
like this video check out more of our
reviews right here